wait comic-con is change is we when we
started this building went to about 1200
I'll and it was all comics a little bit
of toys t-shirts and stuff like that now
obviously it goes down on a sixty eight
hundred or something like that and its
media its its Hollywood its its big
media this is a unique scenario here
it's totally unique it's blown up into
something that's quite different from
your ordinary run-of-the-mill average
comic book convention which is what this
was originally now it's basically a
giant PR monster for movies games and
toys when comics and became big in
movies and when the corporate interests
suddenly turned to Marvel and DC I think
was heart the comic-con it's it's a
little bit like well into bonding man
we're bonding man was this big old
genuinely alternative festival but
suddenly there was Hollywood guys flying
in and we're just to get sex from
girdles and ecstasy you know so it
suddenly became a lot of people became
tourists in this world and I think
that's was heartening with comic-con but
he can't complain you know because
people are so decent we messed all this
cool stuff was happening underneath our
noses where we would be in foreign all
you guys were dressed and often
expressing yourself now we all want a
part of it our expenses go up every year
so cost the smaller guys I'm not that
small obviously with the smaller guys
more and more expense wise and we have
less and less profit so as sooner of it
or later we're all going to dropped out
is just gonna be one big Hollywood thing
it's my fourth year running my company
called raw Studios and we do sci-fi
books crime anything that's not
superheroes and the comic-book stuff is
kind of taking a little bit of a
backseat you know there's still a lot of
geeks here and there's still a lot of
comic book geeks here the fact that
comic books in jazz are the only two
truly original American art forms to
make this experience of San Diego a
unique American experience you've got
commerce you've got giant corporations
and then you've got guys who are just
publishing their own books and they make
500 copies and they run them off on like
a home Xerox machine and staple them
together themselves you can if you have
to accept everyone in but the same thing
is going to lose some of this little
strange
Otzi the quality that has to happen in
the end it says you have to accept